I have today for you maybe one of the
most brilliant pieces of political
satire and political interviewing that
I've seen Sasha Baron Cohen as we've
talked about has a new show on Showtime
it's called who is America Sacha Baron
Cohen you may know from characters such
as Ali G Borat Bruno the dictator he has
a new character who's an Israeli
anti-terrorism expert called
Iran Murad or as the Israelis might say
Evan Mahad
and as Sacha Baron Cohen says during
during his his actual show and in this
interview he speaks two accused serial
child sex assault or Roy Moore who of
course lost the Doug Jones in the
Alabama special election accused by
multiple women including some very young
women of sexually assaulting them it's
unclear when this interview took place
and that's kind of relevant and the
concept is the following Colonel Alan
Mahad says to Roy Moore that they have
developed in Israel a device at piece of
technology which can detect sex
offenders and particularly pedophiles
because they secrete an enzyme called a
D DHT which is supposedly detectable by
this piece of equipment and what he does
is just as a sample he puts it over
himself and then he puts it over Roy
Moore and of course the gag is it beeps
over Roy Moore Roy Moore doesn't know
that it's obviously just like a metal
detectorists
totally standard metal detector and it
gets really really awkward Roy Moore
visibly uncomfortable and ultimately
ends the interview earlier or earlier
than planned take a look at this they
have now used this technology to
identify other abnormalities it turns
out the sex offenders and particularly
pedophiles secrete an enzyme for D DHT
which is actually detectable it is three
times the level of non perverts
so the phrase sweating like a rapist is
actually based on science
so in Israel they have developed a
machine that is used in schools and
playgrounds to detect anyone coming in
and if they detect a pedophile
the one alerts the law enforcement and
schools within a hundred-mile radius it
is very very simple to use you just
switch it on and because neither of us
or sex offenders then it make absolutely
not you just put it on you put it nearby
like this although it must be faulty
it's malfunctioning I'm sure it will do
the same with the other guy here ready
so is this silver jacket yes did you
lend the jacket to somebody else
maybe no I've been married for 33 so I
never had an accusation of such things
I'm not accusing you I thought this is
well then if this is an instrument I did
certainly I'm not a pedophile okay no
but the machine is well I don't know
they may be Israeli technology hasn't
developed properly this is the 99.8%
world it is not saying that you are a
pedophile of course not I am simply
cutting this conversation right now
no thank you have you been nice I
support Israel I don't support this kind
of stuff thank you no it is I'm not
saying that you're a sex offender what
this is just the best and we don't know
when it was filmed and that's sort of
relevant because of course Roy Moore was
accused by multiple people of child
sexual assault strictly speaking it's
not pedophilia because as far as we know
he didn't try to have sex with
prepubescent girls just girls that are
very young and not legally adults in
some states but the funniest part of all
this is that Roy Moore seemed to believe
the technology was legitimate right like
it's just a regular handheld metal
detector it clearly doesn't measure the
secretion of D DHT or any chemical which
would indicate whether somebody is a
pedophile as crazy as the entire thing
isn't as brilliant as the entire thing
is Roy Moore seem to believe that the
technology is real I actually think he
kind of passed the test though right
because if he said that oh this is
actually is not my suit coat it's
someone else I'm borrowing it yeah then
he would have failed right but I think
he found the best way out of this whole
area of that I think he said something
totally boneheaded which is I've been
married 33 years like that doesn't that
doesn't explain whether you do or don't
like little kids right if anything
that's a response that should raise a
red flag because it says nothing about
pedophilia right are you attracted to
prepubescent children
I've been married for 33 years it's
actually a non sequitur when you think
about I guess I'm also just comparing it
to the other Sacha Baron Cohen
interviews yeah like he got one
Republican to blurt out the n-word and
just expose himself he got other
Republicans to advocate for a
kindergardens program where this is very
for year olds
weapons yeah it's much better no news
yet about whether Roy Moore is sending
his Jewish lawyer who we know he has
because he and his wife talked about how
they have a Jewish lawyer in order to
prove that they don't dislike Jews to
sue the colonel here and Sacha Baron
Cohen of course dragging these people
beyond the limits of its absurdity and I
was thinking like how far would he have
to go where no one like everybody gets
that it's just just a goof you know and
I think it would be disturbingly far I
think it would be crazy what he would
have to do to get to a point where
nobody thinks it's a real thing I mean
there have been a few people who have
called him out apparently he showed up
to one gun store yeah
and the owner called him out for being
Borat and there's another congressman
who didn't advocate for the program he
was pushing so it doesn't work every
time if you don't like this tell me why
because I think that this is absolutely
and totally brilliant